excusez moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première fois que je prends un
train de banlieue et vous tous les jours
depuis dix ans vous devez connaître tout
le monde
les habitués à haut de gamme
tentant une expérience une expérience
il s'agit de répondre à une simple
question ok quel genre d'homme est tout
et si je vous demandais de faire une
toute petite chose nous est varié je
vous demanderais quel genre de choses
il y à un intrus à bord vous ne savez
pas à quoi il ressemble tout ce que vous
avez à faire s'est il trouvé
pourquoi je le ferai pour la récompense
oh merde
ne descendait pas du train avant de
l'avoir trouvée n'en parler à personne
il vous regarde
ne m'obligez pas à faire du mal à
quelqu'un que j'aimais
[Musique]
hors de question je refuse go
tu sais pas qui tu as vert
durant vous
ben ouais ça nique
tous les passagers de ce train
vous voulez vivre
mais cap l'on se fout du terrain
vous avez jusqu'au prochain arrêt pour
décider quel genre d'homme est tout
[Musique]